let's jump to this story from EV
magazine we have to do this
evmagazine.com Sam bankman free likely
to be transferred to the same jail where
Jeffrey Epstein allegedly committed
suicide not kill himself I love how EV
magazine actually put allegedly like
they're not gonna just say it despite
the fact the official narrative from all
of the corporate press and everything is
that Epstein did they're they're still
maintaining allegedly so uh Sam bankman
freed you know run an FTX into the
ground and uh gets arrested and now
they're like well you know we're gonna
transfer him to jail and then I have to
imagine
the moment he found out they're like oh
they're transferring you to uh this is
the prison he just I started welling up
because he knows what's coming next have
you been following this at all Kyle
you know uh kind of putting me on the
spot right here uh no no it's nuts it's
like the biggest Financial scam in human
history one of if not the most the
biggest I think I'm gonna have to start
learning some more about it well yeah
but you know we don't need to put you on
the spot yeah
when Luke brought up that the jail
Epstein was in and then you know he was
shuffled off this moral core mortal coil
and now it's imagine his face Sam
bankman freed you saw like the video of
him like running down the street scared
because people saw him yeah this is an
absolutely corrupted jail where the jail
guards still weren't held responsible
for their larger crimes of whatever
happened I mean I'm trying to be careful
with the words here I'll just say when
Epstein was taken out I think that's
more of a fair assessment uh since there
was multiple attempts multiple camera
failures multiple failures of security
multiple procedures that were not
followed the the two prison guards that
were looking on their phone for high
ticket items that they were going to
purchase like motorcycles and expensive
furniture they were of course uh you
know brought to court under federal
charges the federal government uh
essentially gave them a slap on the
wrist they never faced any kind of real
repercussion for it and for that person
Sam bankman free to go to that jail as
he was arrested right before he was
about to give testimony to Congress
really shows you that there might be
something bigger here as many people
question where did he get a lot of that
money from where did all that money come
from as a lot of people are also saying
as soon as Epstein kind of was removed
from the picture there's a lot of money
in play there was still a lot of assets
and money from Jeffrey Epstein that
still hasn't been accounted for a lot of
people are speculating that that money
was moved into SBF in order to continue
the money laundering operation involving
the world economic Forum the bank of
Ukraine and that's how they were kind of
moving money back and forth through all
these Sinister parties some someone said
on the show they said that when when
when the Epstein stuff happened like
right afterwards everything started
unraveling covet Co I mean everything
everything like the world started to
fall apart after that so I felt well
people's consensus people people's
understanding of the world and
participation with it kind of faltered a
little bit because how else could they
not realize that that your tax dollars
were paying for this international
trafficking and extortion operation of
children the people on the left admitted
it the people on the right admitted it
we all agree that this was happening the
corporate media is still lying about it
but the only thing that kept it alive
was a hashtag Jeffrey Epstein didn't
kill himself
for a little bit there exactly what if
the story is Epstein gets recruited to
handle kind of like this International
laundering but then secretly begins this
blackmail operation and turns it on his
handlers and these Global Elites so that
when they're like all right Jeffrey
you're gonna do this and do that and
then he walks in there and goes actually
smoking cigar we're not and then he
presses Planet TV and it shows some like
lewd and lascivious video of a world
leader because that's the theory right
that he was recording these people on
the island and they're like what is this
he's like you're going to do what I want
now what's the possibility that he was
either a patsy or that he was actually
running the show what do you think Luke
it's uh I mean he was one of the players
but he was one of the Disposable players
he was still taking orders obviously
since they took him out but he did have
surveillance cameras hooked up
everywhere in every room especially in
his New York City Mansion there was many
um there was a lot of testimony people
coming forward saying there was cameras
in the bathroom there was cameras in the
hallways there was hidden cameras
everywhere and one of the victims
recently came forward and said Jeffrey
Epstein was very smart when politicians
and powerful people were forcing
themselves onto children he made sure he
wasn't in those uh camera angles and he
made sure that the video footage was
kept in a safe the FBI broke that safe
and then they found a whole bunch of
photos and videos that we still haven't
heard about today doesn't that suggest
he wasn't the pawn that he was the
ringleader I don't know
um we don't know at the end of the day
because we're still scratching the
surface of what we actually know that's
happening here he was a major player
he's one he was one of the biggest
players but he was again a disposable
player that at the end of the day I
think Steve was taking orders I don't
trigger people above him I don't know
though but then he made it to the other
side of the chessboard and thought he
was a queen that's what I'm saying he
flipped it on him because as we were
pointing out like the moment he's gone
every all of this stuff starts
unraveling we start seeing people get
exposed the money starts going wild like
you make a good point maybe it's very
speculative but then FTX starts
funneling this money and now sbf's going
to the same place I wonder if he wasn't
a pawn he was like a centerpiece a
linchpin connecting the dots of all
these things without him the whole thing
just unravels there's a painting by
Maria farmer who was one of the girls
that was trafficked or like victims I
guess if you want to call or survivors
of this whole experience and uh it shows
she like paints all the people that she
remembers being at the island and being
involved at you know Epstein's house in
New York and stuff like that and Jeff is
in the picture in the far right upper
right corner we can probably find the
picture at some point it's called the
sceptiles or the setios SCT Iles and it
shows Jeffrey in a UFO up like he's like
a he was the space cadet he was the
crazy wild face of the a piece of the
movement he cult leader but she
certainly did not peg him as the center
of anything if anything it was giland
Maxwell in the very center of this
picture's Guillain Maxwell the head of a
serpent like the head of a dragon and uh
then you there's lots of other faces
daughter of Robert Maxwell who also was
someone who was deemed a double agent
working with uh Israeli Mossad Russian
intelligence UK intelligence as well uh
a lot of people call them a double agent
and that's why he was kind of taken out
he went on a boat ride and then was
never kind of found again he was
essentially a Rupert Murdoch kind of
figure in the media Glenn Maxwell also
is another kind of fascinating figure
that played a very key Central role here
uh she also very interestingly also had
uh uh helicopter license uh submarine
license as well and yeah she was wasn't
galane in charge of like going to the
boat and getting on the files away from
people after he like disappeared Peter
died what do you mean like the galane
like there's other sisters and like she
was the one that went and got the files
like from the business to keep it safe
you gotta you gotta uh that's I think we
reference some of that but her sisters
are also connected to the FBI and their
database as centers and also to Big Tech
social media as well so it's a big club
and uh we're not in I've been listening
to Whitney Webb interviews about this so
she wrote yeah what new web does some
great great you got to give me a
specific reference yeah
but it made it seem like she was just
like I think Whitney's point was that
Elaine was way more entrenched with
whatever dealings her dad was doing
because she was
um there to collect certain files at the
uh I think after he died but I gotta
check that I got that painting that uh
that Ian referenced yeah and it is it is
crazy yeah it is crazy I mean can we
pull it up it's of course anecdotal uh
this is from Maria Farmer's memory of
what she experienced while she was this
is his Lane right here right in the
middle there's Bezos she's in a bubble
like she's protected oh she's got like a
drag dragon body with a weird deal or
whatever is this Basil's right here what
does that say is that that looks like no
you can start naming names I don't know
if my life is on the line if I do that
but all their faces are right there for
you to look at a name yourself if you
want to this guy they're right in the
middle who's that guy that's Lex westner
oh he's the head of uh uh Bed Bath and
Beyond and and Victoria Secret yeah look
at this look at this guy on the TV
that's like Bill Clinton
this is nuts this look this one here
looks very suggestive it's like a fever
is that hanging in the White House can
you see in the upper right there's
Jeffrey Epstein in a UFO no in the very
upper yeah yeah in the very upper right
in that gray UFO I'm sure that's Jeff
these weird people this is a weird
painting anyway it kind of reminds me of
that old painting of like the guy
reaching through the dimensions
you seen that no what is that old like
carving I heard what they call it but
he's like reaching through this
Dimension to another dimension Kyle were
you in the Matrix or outside of the
Matrix when this story broke Kyle uh
were you in the Matrix or outside the
Matrix when this larger story broke uh
by the by The Matrix do you mean in jail
or yeah yeah or like like as far as like
you were awakened to what's really
happening politically or before
everything happened when you weren't
politically involved when the story
broke I was uh I was not in the Matrix
okay I was wondering what your response
was if you heard this or even if it was
being talked about especially amongst
the the young group of people that you
were hanging out with no no this was not
a conversation piece I'm sitting here
looking at that photograph and I'm just
like wow this is one of this is one of
the most creepiest like photos I've seen
ever it's just like it's just weird and
interesting yeah when you agreed to come
on the show it was like getting pushed
right into the deep end of the pool you
know what I mean it's like you've got
your story we've got stuff to talk about
and then like Luke's just we could go
further down the rabbit we're just
starting we're just kind of digging the
you know on Tucker Carlson just last
week he uh he basically reported that
the CIA killed JFK yeah or that they
were involved in it yeah so it's like
that's I see that all over the place
today huh that's great no one's talking
about that really I just it's it's
strange for me you know I'm sure for
everybody listening that when we're
younger it's like look there's no Global
Elite ring of like trafficking going on
the CIA was not involved as a conspiracy
theories and now I'm looking at my phone
and I'm like what time is it how much
longer until they come out and claim the
moon landing wasn't actually a real
thing like they're just gonna like Chuck
across is gonna come out and be like
we've got new evidence that actually it
was by 5 p.m tonight yeah oh they're
breaking here yeah the conspiracy
theories are coming true yeah what
you've inherited like the the shattered
simulation thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time